clap de fin pour magny les hameaux en
coupe de france le petit poucet blinois
qui évolue en noir ce dimanche s'est
incliné 6 à 2 au troisième tour de la
compétition contre le blanc mesnil
l'équipe qui évolue huit divisions au
dessus des manies croire tactiquement il
était au dessus au niveau du quadrillage
du terrain et touba c'était très
compliqué de les contenir
il y avait des appels de partout est
vraiment un niveau d'écart ça se ressent
on savait à l'avancé que ce serait
difficile après la logique banc
elle fait que à chaque fois ils ont été
réalistes devant le but et
notre côté on a fait ce qu'on a pu on a
pris du plaisir surtout lémanique ont
même fait mieux que de prendre du
plaisir sur le terrain malgré
l'élimination les joueurs ont réussi à
faire douter leurs adversaires pendant
la seconde période en inscrivant deux
buts sur coups de pied arrêtés et en
enchaînant plusieurs séquences de
conservation du ballon
dans notre ve schéma de jeu dans notre
construction de jeu dans la conservation
du ballon il pensait qu'on allait
balancer devant alors qu'on avait essayé
de construire et dans notre phase
défensive
en ce moment c'est une très grande
fierté de marquer surtout que aulas il
voulait pas encaissé de buts qu'ils en
encaissent et d'aujourd'hui nous ça nous
fait du bien au moral pour le reste de
la saison et voilà après cette
parenthèse coupe de france lémanique ou
à devront se mettre rapidement dans le
quotidien du championnat
ils affronteront dès ce dimanche 17
septembre le club de l'ueh civils lors
de la première journée 2 des 4 objectif
monter à la fin de la saison